[Musique]
donc j'ai promis à garou a rendez vous
avec une grosse [ __ ]
normalement il devrait pas me rater
oui c'est bien ici vous avez rendez vous
avec une grosse [ __ ] c'est ce qu'à
ça c'est toi mais oui mais laisse parce
que je suis le truc cochon est un cochon
du tout je pose debout ses doigts eh ben
non médecins samba la vie de la faute
aux nombreux ballons parce que j'ai mis
quelqu'un un peu plus jeune est un peu
plus blond aux wallabies
bravo bravo danièle non pas du tout je
vais bosser pour j'ai bossé pour essayer
de séduire quand je vais commencer par
un petit compliment
on alexandra envers un j'ai bossé vous
reprenez 13 titres de la mythique mot
tonnes cet album illumine mon monotone
automne dans ma vie amoureuse
il ya un sacré trou ça fait longtemps
que j'ai pas eu égard au fait c'est la
trouille
non ça va je pensais qu'il allait partir
mais non alors comme ils disent invite
savoir la sacro-sainte façon les issues
sont bloquées de la porte est fermée
je peux adoré votre album south city
parce que avoir votre belle en fait un
peu trop là à voir votre nouvel organe
dans l'oreille franchement c'est top et
je le souhaite à tout le monde parce que
c'est un grand grand plaisir non mais
c'est vrai votre album est superbe
s'il ya une chanson de nana mouskouri
qui allie codant la veille qui le
connaissait il file à répondre mais
avait pas de la mode à ccc momon papa
j'ai dans l'oreille au très grand saint
luc où m'attendait la moue story
pourtant belge pas un sac rouge penser
que moi aussi alors je leur ai pas moi
j'avais un organe dans l'oreille c'était
pas mal non plus parce que l'équipe est
donc cet album tu dis que cette musique
de l'âme automne c'est viscéral et ça va
même plus bas que levi's r oui c'est
vous battez les viscères
c'est quoi c'est pour moi ça se
concentre un peu plus dans la partie du
haut du poteau non mais
d'accord je repère un gps mais mais
devint d'ailleurs tué à salle pleyel à
paris le 11 décembre 2020 est exactement
j'ai retenu qu'est ce que c'est mais on
se décembre pour l'anniversaire
l'allemagne est non mais j'ai tout prévu
mon ça on peut rêver ça c'est l'idée
c'est vraiment alors dans gala tu as
déclaré mon objectif n'a jamais été
d'être numéro un en quoi que ce soit
mais juste de donner du plaisir à
l'autre chiche ne serait peut-être pas
ton numéro un
moi j'aime pas de numéro ça m'a donné
envie cet album de reprises qui est
tellement réussie de faire une reprise
de tes chansons
au québec ces fantasmes c'est une
reprise d'une de ses chansons ont très
très saine
tél j'aimerais vraiment qu'ils me roule
une pelle
alors j'ai sorti mais ne rame je me suis
pris un vent mais avant garde
[Musique]